le concours
2021 a été attribué au premier tour par
six voire à mohamed m.go gars art pour
son roman publié aux éditions philippe
rey gym san la plus secrète mémoire des
hommes
[Musique]
c'est une fierté une satisfaction
nationale venant peu du goût gaza et
quand on parle de mort mais de mauvais
ça c'est d'abord le produit un produit
local qui a fait ses humanités dans
l'évent ici au sénégal avant de partir
en europe ou suivre des études en
littérature je pense que le sentiment
est le même c'est un sentiment de fierté
de reconnaissance et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est à l'assaillant que
du bonheur
[Musique]
je pense que ce qui a fait la différence
peut-être c'est que la russie alliée de
cultures différentes la culture
française européens de façon générale
dans la culture africaine il assure et
vous utilisez des arts qui relève de
l'oralité et d'autre part qui relève
également de l'écriture
[Musique]